I think by this point now we're pushing
three years later the public has seen
the evidence and no matter what NPR says
no matter what the Crooked Pfizer
spokesman say I think people know what
is up and and so we no longer trust big
Pharma you know living in a country
where you can't even trust big Pharma
Executives what has this nation come to
and so now the question for us is what
do we do about it these are the people
who lied to us about the origin of covid
about the virulence of covid about the
efficacy of the vaccines about the
safety of the vaccines about the tests
that they subjected the vaccines do they
lie to us about everything the masks and
the social distancing and the whole
kitten caboodle so what are we going to
do about it I think this is the the part
where at least the conservatives if not
more good faith liberals and people in
the center will go in and say we need to
wield the political order to punish
Pfizer